as of guys my name is Ayana welcome back
to my game engine series so last time we
separated our project house into hazel
editor check out that video if you
haven't already and it seems that
everyone likes the name hazel nut which
is nice because so do I those of you who
have no idea what I'm talking about we
have made a new project called hazel
editor which is going to be the level
editor for hazel and the the name that
it has inside the development branch of
hassle is hazel nut that's just what
I've called it I don't know why it just
randomly happened but people seem to
like it so I guess we'll we'll make it
hazel nut if anyone objects to this
write a comment but I think that we
that's pretty much solved but that is
not all we're going to do today don't
worry what we what we're gonna do today
is we're gonna continue on our I am GUI
viewport journey this is really the
viewport journey and specifically the
part that we're up to is making it so
that we instead of just assuming some
kind of resolution which is 1280 by 720
in this case we need to actually bring
the viewport which is a frame buffer out
into its own I'm GUI panel and then
based on the size of that panel set our
frame buffer size so that we can render
our scene appropriately and that is what
we're going to be doing today so let me
just switch into this mode and and we
can take a look at that so it's not a
particularly difficult job if I launch
havel editor at the moment actually
let's rename it to hazel not as our
first order of business because I will
just forget to do that eventually and
that won't be a that'll be a bad thing
so hazel editor which i think is weird
hazel - oh ok so we're just going to
rename this to hazel nut location will
be hazel nut and that I think is it so
if I go back here all we really need to
do is rename this to hazel nut now the
folder and then rerun the script and I
think that should work let's reload
Vittel studio and everything should be
as before all and one more thing we
forgot to do that was actually set our
start up project I think that's already
open it's just a side project at sandbox
so let's maybe change the start project
to be hazel not because I think we'll
get it working at the end of this
that'll just change it from sandbox to
hazel
as a default start project if if you
don't have like a visual studio settings
file that already does that so and then
a hazel editor app will rename to
hazelnut up and then hazelnut that that
didn't really work hazelnut is our
application and hazel okay so a little
bit of refactoring but we've got
hazelnut hazelnut is now live now we
just needed some kind of nut logger
probably a hazelnut logo or maybe a
walnut logo for hazelnut would be a
funny thing to do I am full of humor as
you can see okay so we've got this
viewport as you can see we're just
setting it to 1280 by 720 if we look at
our editor layout that is in fact what
it's set to over here or here because I
always get these two branches kind of
mixed up but what we want to do instead
is actually first of all create a new
viewport so let's do that this is what
kind of this is the dock space and I
think this is our settings window this
is the beginning of our settings window
then we do our start and then this is
the end so wait we don't want to do this
in the settings window we actually want
to make a new winter I'm going to begin
and this is going to be called viewport
this is our viewport window and then
we'll do I am going end so there's a way
to see how big this is and the function
called I am GUI get viewport get get
content region available available I
guess which is going to give us I think
a vector you have an eye on vector which
is going to be the size of our viewport
so viewport panel size let's say now
there is some kind of padding and other
things that we'll have to deal with in a
minute but that's basically that's the
gist of it so if I call printf here I
don't know why I'm doing that because
we've clearly got like H said H said one
so if you port size zero one and if I
chuck in viewport panel size dot X you
bought panel size dot y if I just run
that really quickly then we should say
that hopefully that that's that's what
we're after and okay so first of all
you'll notice the viewport
which is cool we can dock it anywhere we
want here this is the Settings panel
I'll move it there now this as you can
see it's kind of working already but
it's not really it's just still
rendering that huge image and you can
see there is a little bit of padding if
you look like in the top-left corner
anyway clearly if we resize this it
doesn't really care it weird things
happen if we move it down like this
there's just a lot of problems with it
but hopefully I've moved it a bit this
viewport size should now kind of be
dynamic I guess and I can't minimize the
main window of course but if I look at
the viewport size and I change it you
can see that this size changes so this
is what we're after these values these
values are what is going to feed into
our I am into our frame buffer so if
that size changes we want to recreate
the frame buffer with a new size which
is fairly easy to do so to do that we're
going to store the viewport size so
we'll say and we need to store this mmm
how do we store this
we'll just saw this is the back -
probably I mean we can - we might as
well store as an iron back to it yes
these are floats anyway I believe so
there's no real difference I guess just
for consistency we'll explore as as a
bacterium so we'll do em viewport size
and we'll just say viewport size equals
viewport panel size that ex and viewport
panel size or Y so the idea is that if
the if viewport size and I'll just I
guess I'll do Jill I'm back to Newport
size and I mean you could type on this
because they are they do have the same
memory layout so in other words and I
guess I don't know if we should do that
usually people don't like it when I do
dangerous stuff but if we what we can do
here is we can simply say if viewport
size does not equal and then we can do a
little GLM back to pupil panel size like
that right so what this is going to do
and we might need more of these things
so we need an asterisk here and this and
that so basically what that's doing is
it's assuming the viewport panel size is
actually this type because we're casting
the memory address of it to a vector
pointer and then dereferencing it as a
vector so that both vector is now
viewport size and this will probably
rewrite this code in a minute because it
is a little bit dangerous but it should
be fairly safe because the memory layout
is the same if we look at an I am I am
back to its two floats x and y and
that's obviously what a GL ember two is
as well so there's no reason to kind of
construct a whole new object and copy
all that data if you're just dealing
with the same kind of memory layout
however it is two floats and it's not
the end it's not the end of the world if
you do copy it and it will probably be
nicer to read so we'll change it in a
minute but let's not get too hung up on
this so if it is different first of all
we should probably assign it I mean we
can do that anyway but if it is
different will assign us and then we'll
also need to recreate the frame buffer
so we'll have to do M frame buffer and
then we can do probably maybe like well
we can do two things right we can always
do the invalidate function but I think
I'll just do resize so I'll give it a
new size I'll resize it and I'll say
that we want to resize it to the
viewport panel size this is another
reason why it would have been better to
do it um you know to have it as a GL n
back to anyway so that's going to
recreate the whole frame buffer so we
need to add that API in of course so
unbind unbind is fine but we'll also add
a resize and I guess we'll take in a
size here although is probably good to
have to like you know integers as well
because that's typically how you'd want
to create these things I don't know if a
vector like this is gonna be a
necessarily a good API to have in fact
if we look at what OpenGL frame buffer
actually wants it wants a GL size I
which I think I mean how we storing them
here as you and 32 T's I mean to me it
makes no sense to have an API like this
just cost your variables or whatever so
I will actually separate them so
and 33 width and height like this and we
will grab this will set it equal to zero
we'll grab this and with the virtual and
we'll go to OpenGL frame buffer we will
pop that in with the override keyword
we'll implement that function one thing
I forgot to do I think because I saw a
comment or something is that it I'm not
actually deleting the textures which is
a big mistake you know we want to do GL
delete textures and then we'll delete
them separately will delete the color
attachment and also the depth attachment
so that was a bit bit of mistake there
cuz we're creating textures we should
delete them okay so that's done now
resize so what does resize do we'll
resize at this point basically does this
right so it basically will recreate the
frame buffer and it'll do everything now
I'm not sure if we necessarily should be
deleting I guess we should be deleting
the whole frame buffer it might be
better to just detach I don't know if
you can detach a textures I want to
quickly see what hazel dev is doing but
I think that it is just deleting
everything so let's do that so I'm gonna
copy this I'm gonna paste it into resize
but there's gonna be an interesting
block of code here because it's going to
actually and in fact I don't know if we
necessarily need to do this let's just
maybe extend invalidate to do it so this
will have an if statement that basically
checks to see if render ID is set so
render IDs set right because if you look
at this we're going to initialize it to
0 like we'll do for everything else so
this is you know when we create a new
frame buffer if it doesn't exist hopeful
for whatever reason it will be set to 0
but then if it's so in other words the
first time we construct this and we call
invalidate and render ID is of course 0
because this is where we created but if
it has been set so if it's not 0 we want
to delete everything that way now we've
cleaned everything and we want to make a
new frame buffer because that's how you
resize them so and get rid of this I
guess so will recreate the whole frame
buffer and that's what invalidate will
do so really in resize all we need to do
then is we need to actually update the
specification by setting the width and
height to the new width and height and
then just invalidate it and then that
should be it so I'll call invalidate I
think that's it so if we go back into
editor layer which surprising they don't
have pinned then when we call resize we
can do resize pupil size X the viewport
size Y which we can just move it the way
that I was originally doing in but we'll
also need to make sure that we cost it
332 T there should be integers and I
think we're good
that was fairly easy to do and then well
of course so we're recreating the frame
buffer on this line and then we're
getting the color attachment and
rendering a bit now this was done in a
different thread like the whole like if
OpenGL was done on a different thread I
think that this would be a slightly
potentially slightly incorrect because I
mean not necessarily it's just it's not
gonna synchronize between reciting the
viewport and then getting a new frame
buffer so we might get a frame or sew
over the old frame buffer rendering but
this is a blocking call at the moment
which I think will resize the frame
buffer and then that way because the
color attachment render ID changes
that's the whole point and that's why
I'm saying all of this because the
render ID will probably be different so
since it's gonna because we're deleting
the old one and making a new one so
that's just a little bit of an important
piece of information there but I think
everything else is good the last piece
of the puzzle is making sure that this
of course is correct
so this is our width and height so this
now has to be M viewport size dot X and
M viewport size dot Y okay so this is a
bit of a mess now because we have
casting types and doing all this stuff
but I think it might work so let's hit
f5 and see what happens I still don't
have a shirt that says that I need to
get on that ok cool so there's our
viewport and if I resize it you can see
that this whole thing
we'll change right so I can break it off
here if I want to I can grab this I can
resize it to any size I want almost any
size I want that that for some reason is
not being set correctly did I do
something silly here I'm just making
sure I don't have X twice or something
like that and it looks fairly fairly
okay we might need to set the Open GL
viewport I mean hi it seems to be
working it is stretching it as you can
see there's a lot of reasons for that
but in general it should be in fact
taking the size let's dock this maybe it
should be taking the size of well of
whatever we have here and scrolling
isn't work because I'm getting the
events but there you go right so we have
a resizable viewport now let's get rid
of this padding now to get rid of this
padding there's something called was
just I think it's just the window
padding so what we can do is before we
wrap me we begin this viewport window we
can actually set a style sets push style
bar sir
push a style variable and this is the
window
I'm GUI style by just looking at hazel
dev window padding and if we set that to
zero here and then we pop it after we're
done with this window so that all the
other windows don't have a padding of
zero then I think that should make it
fullscreen because that's what I ended
up doing for hazel dev yep and there you
can see now that we don't have a border
around it it's now the correct size now
while also we also generally want to
change the viewport what I end up doing
is inside the frame buffer bind call I
set the viewport because the frame
buffer if we're rendering to a frame
buffer we probably want the viewport to
be the size of the frame buffer so once
I find it I just do gel view board zero
zero and a specification dot with and a
specification Delhi and that might fix
our little issue of it not rendering
fullscreen and then also we need to set
the projection yeah it did fixed I can
tell it as link because
different so you can see now we can
really make it any size and it's going
to fill up the whole frame here or at
least it should yeah that is that it
that's actually part of it as well that
kind of great bought it that's how clear
color so it is in fact filling
everything and then if I resize it to
any size it should I'm moving like
Visual Studio panels here but it should
be pretty much perfect so what I need to
do is let's fix the camera that's not
the biggest issue what we need to do at
this point is basically how we been
doing the camera where is my camera
camera controller updates I don't know
if necessarily the on event should be
how we do this we probably just do it
here so what we'll do is we'll call em
camera controller dot will say set
camera orthographic camera I guess we
can just do SEP projections
can't we mm because the way the way that
the camera changes especially for an
orthographic camera is going to be
completely up to the camera itself so
it's a little bit difficult to do this
because it's you know it's kind of
camera specific but because we're very
closely linked with an orthographic
camera here we can just do camera
control look at get camera don't set
projection left right bottom top so what
do we initialize the camera to its well
we just do camera control or do we
really don't have any code that deals
with resizing I feel like this has been
a thing that I'll window resize event
does it and it sets it to aspect ratio
time zoom level well that's all we need
so really this is kind of what we need
what I'll do is I will add a function
here called maybe resize bounds and
resize bounds is going to take in
in its place float with float hi try do
it jack click on resize maybe just
resize I don't know honor on kind of to
me in a way implies that this an engine
level event although not necessarily
let's just do on on resize whatever
we'll call it that I want to get hung up
on this so what I'll do is you know we
know that oh yeah I guess we can just do
within height so the way that we'll do
this is we'll set aspect ratio equal to
width divided by height over here and
then everything else is done so if we do
on resize with width and high like that
that's what happens when we zoom in and
out oh sorry that's what happens when we
resize the window it's all we need to do
just call the on resize function here
and that should work and it gets to be
we just put in the width and the height
and then over here inside where are we
then all we need to do here is do camera
controller on resize and then the width
and height so that's going to be our
more basically just this so now we
should hopefully be resizing our camera
every time the windows resize and
remember the first frame this will be
different because well we're not only
thing we're even initializing this so
maybe we should just make that 0 0 or
something like that but it doesn't
really matter it's going to be different
than the actual viewport panel size
which is what this is and because it's
going to be different we're going to
trigger this code here once until we
resize again and that's going to
basically set up a frame buffer to the
correct size set up our viewport to the
right size which is basically going to
set the camera so that's that so now
everything should be the correct aspect
ratio if I resize the window or whatever
you can see hopefully that everything is
correct if I end up doing this it zooms
in a lot because that's just how a
camera works and I can drag this around
too
sighs really I can break off the
viewport here and I can you know resize
it as you can see to any size and the
camera stays pretty much well it stays
the right aspect ratio which is what I
was looking for that that's it
that is our fairly and flawless viewport
implementation yeah so now you can see
we have settings here and it's a doc
panel I don't like this whole flashing
situation I'm not a hundred percent sure
why that's happening it might be
something to do with the fact that we're
rendering with either an invalid texture
ID or something for a single frame which
is actually happening over here what is
this stupid branch situation
docking enabled true dockings always
going to be enabled for this let's get
rid of this this is back one we had this
in the sandbox project I didn't want to
destroy the sandbox project but this is
now its own project and everything's
fine okay so now we've gotten rid of
that stupid area yeah I'm not sure I
think that maybe it has something to do
with this because we shouldn't really
have a frame of black like we do there I
think that's because we're probably
giving it an incorrect texture ID or
something like that because maybe it
hasn't finished resizing I'm not upset
short because obviously it should be
done I think by the time we do this
anyway if you guys know the solution to
that then definitely open up a pull
request or something like that and the
first person who does so will get a
prize which will be like I don't know
I'll probably just thank you for it
publicly so hopefully that's that's nice
hopefully that's a good enough price
anyway that's it so now we have a
viewport exciting stuff events I wanted
this video been gone for just like 20
minutes okay let's quickly see if we can
fix the events the events so I am GUI
layer at the moment I think does some
little blocking code in certain
situations so if it wants to capture the
mouse or the keyboard it block stuff I
did not add this code which is wise here
which is why nothing's working this is
like reporter first so thank you
community this is not supposed to be
here and if we don't do this I mean you
need this to some degree but just not in
this way now you can see everything
works perfectly it also means that if I
scroll here it also works
and that's that's kind of the place
where it's not good because we don't
want to receive events everywhere we
only want to receive the events
basically if the mouse is being hovered
on the viewport and is that's also
important because if we try and access
this and we type in W I'm typing in W
but it's I mean I can't because it's
like a number field but I'm typing s and
W and it's moving my viewport that's not
what we want either but this is just a
way to kind of quickly get events
working so I will leave this code as is
but just know that this is not the
solution and we'll be doing something
slightly different in the future anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this video thank
you for watching
next time I don't even know what we're
gonna do next time because we basically
got the viewport working and we've got
frame buffers now I think I don't know
I'll probably think of that when we
begin the next video but thank you guys
so much for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please hit the like button
please use the comment section below to
express your thoughts and feelings about
everything and anything and what you
would like to see next I guess and maybe
I'll work on that I know we have a list
somewhere on trailer so I'll open that
up next time and we will talk about that
don't forget that you can help support
the series by going to patreon.com 4/2
the Cherno and you'll get access to like
the hazel dev live streams and the
source code to the more advanced kind of
private version of hazel and you'll be
ensuring that I can continue working on
this series so thank you so much to
everyone
for all of your support have a great day
and I will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]